i
[Música]
el senado de eeuu determinó que si es
constitucional el juicio contra el
expresidente de donald trump a pesar de
que éste ya dejó el cargo ahora
enfrentará un proceso en el legislativo
por haber instado a la violencia que
llevó a la toma del capitolio poniendo
en riesgo la seguridad del país y de las
instituciones en minutos conectamos con
nuestro corresponsal en la ciudad de
washington
pese a haber abandonado el poder los
demócratas buscan cerrarle a trump la
posibilidad de aspirar a un cargo
público o su posible regreso a la casa
blanca la carta bajo la manga radica en
la sección 3 de la decimocuarta enmienda
de la constitución de eeuu que prohíbe
ejercer cargos públicos a quienes han
participado o ha ayudado en
insurrecciones
y perú dio inicio al plan de vacunación
en medio de la división que hay entre
los ciudadanos que se oponen al proceso
de inmunización contra el hobbit 19 en
una primera instancia es el personal de
salud y las personas en riesgo los que
están recibiendo estas primeras 300.000
dosis de la vacuna sino fun
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por estar con nosotros
a esta hora vamos a comenzar en la
ciudad de washington la capital de
estados unidos concentra la atención
internacional después de esa votación de
56 votos a favor y 44 en contra en el
senado de eeuu que aprobó así la
constitucionalidad del juicio contra el
ex presidente de donald trump el ex
mandatario es acusado por instar a la
violencia desatada en la toma del
capitol del pasado 6 de enero que según
la cámara de representantes- puso en
peligro la seguridad del país y de las
instituciones de ese país vamos a
conectar con cristóbal vázquez
corresponsal de france 24 hoy en la
capital de eeuu para conocer más
detalles él ha estado siguiendo esta
noticia a lo largo del día y nos va a
contar un poco más quienes fueron
cristóbal estos senadores republicanos
que votaron a favor de la
constitucionalidad de este segundo
juicio político contra donald trump
exacto y esto lo mencionaba fueron 56
votos a favor de la constitucionalidad
de segundo proceso político juicio
político contra un presidente en eeuu y
44 en contra de la constitucionalidad le
doy los seis nombres de los republicanos
susan collins de maine bill cassidy de
luisiana lisa murkowski de alaska mitt
romney como se esperaba de yuta venes al
de nebraska y pat tomei de pensilvania
este es uno nuevo que muchos no
consideraban en la lista de republicanos
que apoyaron el segundo juicio político
llama la atención que me marcó android
que tanto criticó a donald trump a por
haber auspiciado por haber incitado a
esta estos simpatizantes que se tomaron
el capitolio el 6 de enero haya votado
en contra de la constitucionalidad de
este segundo juicio político
cristóbal cómo le fue entonces a la
defensa de donald trump porque están
siendo criticados que dijeron ellos hoy
a lo largo de la jornada mientras el
senado debatida
si eran nueve fiscales que son
representantes a la cámara demócratas
que fueron seleccionados por la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes para que en el senado
representarán al partido demócrata en el
proceso de impeachment en versus estos
dos abogados que contrató donald trump
hace una semana los dos abogados son
bruce castrol y deivid show en muy
criticado fue bruce caster y se les
critica sobre todo pues la falta de
precisión en las citas la falta de
conocimiento de la minucia de la ley
sobre todo en lo que tiene que ver con
la enmienda 14 que dice que pues una
presidente de cualquier funcionario
público en funciones no puede estar
relacionado o haber apoyado algún acto
de insurrección pues cuando dio la cita
y cuando citó a otros medios de
comunicación lo hizo de forma imprecisa
además se presentó con una libreta
amarilla como de apuntes como no
tomándola con mucha seriedad una una
fecha y un momento tan importante para
eeuu y para la defensa de donald trump y
se critica también a david show de haber
sido bastante pasional bastante
activista parecía un simpatizante más de
donald trump con su tono bastante
ferviente apoyando al ex presidente do
not want de hecho island
alén el abogado anterior del ex
presidente de donald trump en el primer
juicio alan del corts y dijo dijo que
pues no entendía muy bien que estaba
haciendo la defensa de donald trump en
esta ocasión dijo que no lo estaba
haciendo muy bien lo dijo a newsmax a un
medio republicano así que si esto se
compara además el buen la buena
presentación con pruebas y con vídeos
que hicieron los demócratas pues así en
contraste bastante bastante importante
cristóbal que sigue entonces en la
agenda para esta semana esta fue un
primer paso en este juicio político
claro a partir de mañana al mediodía
empiezan ya los argumentos formales
entonces los demócratas liderados por
estos nueve representantes a la cámara
específicamente por jamie rating pues
tendrán 16 horas para presentar los
argumentos de por qué el presidente el
ex presidente de donald trump pues debe
ser padre y debe ser juzgado en este
juicio político y tendrán 16 horas
también la defensa de donald trump los
dos abogados que le acabo de mencionar
estas 16 horas claras serán extras serán
usadas en dos días diferentes después
vendrán las preguntas de los senadores y
después vendrá entonces
el tiempo en la que se cita uno a los
testigos para después tener la votación
final gracias cristóbal por este reporte
desde la ciudad de washington el debate
de la constitucionalidad de este juicio
político radicaba en que donald trump ya
dejó el cargo como presidente es por
esto que se abre entonces un nuevo
debate al interior sobre una cláusula de
la constitución de eeuu
impedir que trump aspiren nuevamente a
un cargo público en el futuro se trata
de la sección 3 de la decimocuarta
enmienda de la constitución una parte
que es poco conocido que cierra entonces
el camino a cualquiera que haya
participado en la insurrección o
rebelión contra eeuu esto también
incluye ayuda o apoyo para que puedan
ocupar nuevamente pues unos cargos
públicos en el futuro que también es
este escenario pues lo vamos a discutir
con nuestro analista invitado emilio
viano emilio muy buenas noches como
siempre un gusto saludarlo aquí en
france 24 y estaba mencionando esta
enmienda de la constitución de eeuu que
tan viable que tan aplicada puede ser
para este caso para este juicio en
particular contra donald trump
bueno claramente es una posibilidad pero
yo pienso que no será tan fácil porque
uno tiene que demostrar en una manera
digamos convincente que el presidente
intento de desatar una insurrección en
contra del gobierno establecido de los
eeuu
claramente esto es el punto principal
del proceso procedimiento de destitución
pero es más fácil si se puede hacer con
el procedimiento de destitución que con
esta enmienda que a donde uno tiene que
demostrar más la digamos la intención de
hacerlo más que sencillamente el hecho
que habló en esta manera pero claramente
es una posibilidad de la cual no se ha
hablado mucho porque es una una vértigo
de la constitución que es casi
desconocido por muchísima gente
y dadas las condiciones que están dadas
hoy después de esta votación pues todos
los escenarios son posibles señor viano
a lo largo de la jornada de hoy uno de
los abogados de donald trump dijo que
este juicio en contra del expresidente
partiría a eeuu entonces generaría una
herida profunda y muy difícil de cerrar
para eeuu es un país que ya está
polarizado pero si lo vemos en
perspectiva finalmente es una persona
que simplemente está respondiendo por
sus actos ante la justicia puede generar
entonces más divisiones de las que ya
hay
bueno esto es a veces ha sido la
política muy exitosa de trump de
presentarse como una víctima una víctima
desde el comienzo mismo de su
candidatura para la presidencia hace
años y por supuesto desde que empezó a
ser presidente para decidir el ser
presentado mucho como una víctima de una
conspiración de los demócratas de
negarles el éxito de no reconocer sus
logros de no apoyar sus iniciativas y
ahora víctima de un robo de un fraude él
debería ser el presidente lo robaron
fraudulentamente la funcionando muy bien
con su base con sus seguidores porque
sus devotos lo considera naturalmente
alguien que necesita su apoyo y ha
generado también una cantidad de dinero
muy larga al mismo después que dejó la
presidencia para ayudarlo a combatir
digamos este tipo de victimización así
que esto es un poco lo que es utilice
mucho
presentar a trump no como un victimario
comencé como quieren hacer los
demócratas por lo que él hizo con su
discurso desatando la insurrección con
el capitolio pero como víctimas de los
demócratas desde el comienzo por eso que
uno de los abogados de defensa de trump
presentó un vídeo con una cronología de
todas las relaciones de demócratas que
querían deshacerse de trump desde que
comenzó su presidencia señor díaz no
miremos hacia adelante lo que sigue en
los escenarios posibles para esta semana
que cree usted que va a suceder en la
política de eeuu a raíz de este juicio
político contra donald trump
pero claramente la división ya existe
más de 80 millones de norteamericanos
votaron para bailar 64 millones para
trump así que hay una división muy
fuerte en el país que hace 50 por ciento
50% no va a cambiar esto más o menos
continúa como ya fue y claramente
siempre hay la posibilidad digamos qué
trampa intervenga pero ahora no puede
participar más en twitter así que no
puede hablar tan fácilmente como como
antes yo creo que el procedimiento va a
desarrollarse muy normalmente para la
presentación de la de los fiscales de la
cámara de representantes para los
abogados de defensa estoy segura que
trump no está muy contento con ellos por
su digamos manera de presentar su caso
hoy y esperar a que hagan mejor eso se
puede también atribuir al hecho que
cinco abogados que
tenían que representar trampa hace días
dejaron su empeño con él porque él
quería que la defensa se concentrará
sobre su victimización que hablaron no
de él no del de la insurrección no de su
discurso a sus devotos aquí en
washington pero de el hecho que le
habían robado la elección ellos dijeron
si no lo vamos a hacer porque no
funciona en los dos abogados de hoy no
era muy bien preparado era obvio señor
viana muchas gracias por este análisis
para la audiencia de france 24 un gusto
hablar con usted como siempre muchas
gracias vamos a cambiar de tema y otros
temas destacados de la jornada vamos
hasta perú este país dio inicio al plan
de vacunación contra el jove y 19 en
medio de divisiones entre los ciudadanos
en cuanto a este proceso de inmunización
según algunos sondeos casi la mitad de
la población de perú se opone en esta
primera fase será el personal de salud
el que reciba las dosis de la vacuna
scinopharm que es desarrollada en china
y de las cuales perú recibió 300.000
dosis
el informe de juan pupilas
un carnet y una sonrisa encubierta un
recuerdo de una jornada histórica en la
que ellos el personal de salud de
primera línea de batalla contra el
comité 19 son los protagonistas pero
comenzó en lima a la capital su
vacunación contra el 19 en una etapa
inicial que tiene como objetivo inocular
a un millón de personas entre
profesionales sanitarios militares y
policías me parecía muy lejos
una parte de este proceso
y me parece un sueño
y hasta en la vacuna y que nos estemos
comienza un proceso que llena de
esperanza al segundo país de américa con
la mayor tasa de mortalidad por cada
100.000 habitantes por el nuevo
coronavirus sólo superado por eeuu los
lotes de la vacuna ya partieron fuera de
lima a otras regiones como huánuco una
de las zonas más castigadas por el
hobbit 19 en el horizonte una siguiente
fase para vacunar a 5,3 millones de
adultos mayores con enfermedades
preexistentes se ha empezado por vacunar
a nivel nacional todos los
establecimientos que cuentan con una
unidad de cuidados intensivos todo el
personal asistencial del establecimiento
el que tiene que ver con contacto
directo con los pacientes se vacuna
primero hay alivio por el comienzo de la
vacunación siendo perú el sexto país de
sudamérica en dar inicio a este proceso
la mala noticia llega desde la
asociación nacional de periodistas de
perú que afirma que en 10 meses
108 reporteros han perdido la vida a
causa del cobi 19 según ellos la cifra
más alta en el mundo en nuestros temas a
los 76 años y de manera repentina según
su representante falleció la
de mar y wilson una de las fundadoras
del reconocido grupo the supremes wilson
falleció en su casa en la ciudad de las
vegas en donde recibía las causas de su
muerte no han sido especificadas aún
sólo dos días antes de su fallecimiento
el artista publicó un vídeo en su canal
de youtube anunciando que estaba
trabajando con universal music para
presentar un álbum en solitario con
material inédito con estas imágenes
terminamos este informativo de france 24
siga con nosotros
[Música]